[Music]
hey you guys happy tuesday or whatever
[ __ ] day it is tuesday last night we saw
that uh what is it last night in soho
yeah that's why we didn't stream
yesterday because we had one we hadn't
seen a movie and i said well let's go
see last night in soho so we can talk
about that on tuesday in the dolby
theater because i will be yeah i've been
waiting to see this for like a really
long time i was impressed it was much
better than i thought it was going to be
alex hammond asked is this film a chick
flick because that's the vibe i got when
i saw the trailer not by any stretch the
imagination i'm not really sure what
genre i would call it it's kind of a
mystery thriller supernatural
elements supernatural thriller
and it also kind of has a throwback sort
of
giallo look to it and it's also kind of
um edgar wright who directed it he is uh
was also on record of saying
that he was inspired by repulsion yeah
the roman polanski film
um you know and kind of like your early
70s yeah italian horror also the the the
trailer seems to spoil this movie it
doesn't that's not you're just only
scratching the [ __ ] tip of the
iceberg with them with the trailer so i
was like man haven't they just given the
story away
a lot more to it than that
it's like a supernatural
thriller horror movie
about this
british chick from the country raised by
her grandma she's kind of sheltered she
goes off to college
to go to fashion school
and she was real wrapped up into retro
stuff she's kind of like a
kind of like a like like a hipster she's
big into the 60s because her grandma was
into that her mama died she never met
her mom no she did her mom's little kid
her mom killed herself when she was
seven that's right when she was seven
yeah
um
so uh it was the other girl i think that
one that she was thomas that's beside
the point
um anyway
she
uh she has this um
psychic ability
her grandmother calls it a gift
and uh it's almost kind of like
something out of damn star wars where
they can like force visions or something
she can see the past
and she can see the spirits of the dead
and sometimes it's kind of like she's
actually projected to the into the past
where she's
feels like she's in
the place of this girl who's going
through this thing it's like a murder
mystery going on
and there's a lot of [ __ ] we can't spoil
um because it would just totally [ __ ]
the movie up it there's all kinds of
[ __ ] that happens out of left field do
not see any reviews or spoilers don't
read anything about the movie just go to
see it
um it's got real good score super good
score super good soundtrack
shot real well
uh color palettes really good
um
it's got a lot of um kind of like
elements of a gangster movie
um elements of like uh supernatural
thriller
um it's got kind of like some erotica
angles to it lots of good song and dance
acts in the [ __ ] 60s and in goth
clubs because then the weird [ __ ] starts
happening to where she starts kind of
going
and
goth
her style starts changing and they kind
of draw parallels between
the the 19 differences too between like
the 1960s club
scene and like the present day like goth
industrial type scene there's
there is like some interplay she's
having visions when she's in clubs and
[ __ ]
and um she's trying to unwrap this
[ __ ] murder mystery and it [ __ ] is
weird as [ __ ] it's good real good i
liked it very much yeah i'm just the
thing about it though is that
when we were watching it like i said
when we saw the trailers because i've
seen the trailer a bunch of times i was
like oh that looks really good and like
i said it's edgar wright who obviously
did you know shawn of the dead he did uh
scott pilgrim versus the world baby
driver so he's done like all these uh
well he did the whole cornetto trilogy
not just he did hot fuzz and all that
too um so i was really excited to see
this and i was like ooh that looks
really good it looks like a throwback to
a giallo movie and then like when i was
watching i was like but some like the
trailer i was like god it seems to like
give the whole thing away
in the sense that it establishes that
she can see ghosts or psychic visions or
whatever it establishes that she's
really into the 60s and she's
essentially having a vision of this
woman that she sees back in the 60s and
you're led to believe that she's
murdered and that the person who
murdered her is still alive nowadays and
is kind of like after uh you know the
main girl who said her name's ellie the
character name
uh played by thomas and mackenzie
and
so was so when i was watching the movie
i'm just kind of like well i kind of
hope that it does something else because
i thought that the trailer kind of
spoiled the whole movie
um but then it goes off and i was like
oh well i did not expect that
so i was so i'm saying it's i'm not
saying it goes like off the rails but it
goes there's twists there's a twist that
happens that
yeah there's a couple twists that i
actually did not see coming the first
one i kind of saw it but not until
right before you know you were supposed
to see it and then the last twist i was
like yeah i didn't see that coming at
all yeah and it kind of doesn't come out
and just know where they do kind of lay
the groundworks forward if you're paying
attention on some of the stuff if you're
paying attention you go like oh okay
that foreshadowed something that
happened later um but you you have to
know you know
you only notice it in like retrospect
um
but aside from all that it's a it's a
fun watch because it has a lot of cool
song and dance numbers in it like
cabaret style [ __ ] back in the 60s bunch
of hotties in it
a lot of sexual undertones kind of like
gangsters violence and [ __ ]
cops and [ __ ]
psychics and
goth scene stuff happens in it good
music um
you're like what the [ __ ] is going on
she's
kind of
going into these trances and going into
the past and seeing what happened to
this girl
some of the [ __ ] she tries to [ __ ]
stop it
and so on a couple occasions she
actually got a reaction to people in the
past so economy leads you to wonder
if
people in the past sometimes saw her
because she seemed to influence remember
a dude reacted to her
but it's kind of deniable you don't
really know was he
was she did she just envisioned that or
did that dude in the past see her for a
second it's hard to know it's hard to
know and it's it is a psychic thing
that's going on though she's not
imagining it although people think are
telling her she's crazy
well and they do leave a little bit of
ambiguity in the sense that
you know they established that her
mother had the similar thing to her like
had the psychic powers and couldn't
handle it like her mom had also gone to
london like the big city that she's from
cornwall and she kind of lives out in
the country and like you said she's kind
of old-fashioned and like kind of
sheltered and stuff but she just has
this love for
london but more the london of the 60s
and more like an idealized london of the
60s yeah so it's almost kind of like i
feel like she intellectually she she
thinks she can handle yeah go into this
big city but then when she gets there
it's like way more overwhelming than she
thought um so she kind of has a hard
time fitting in
and then um but they do kind of set up
that her mom like had went on a similar
journey and couldn't handle it and ended
up killing herself so they do introduce
some ambiguity that it could be
that ellie
is maybe just having some kind of like
breakdown like her mom had i don't think
that's the case no it's not but i have
seen a couple other reviewers that said
you could read it that way if you wanted
to yeah but it would be it would just be
this
statistically [ __ ] no no no
the chances of her just happen to being
in the right place at the right time and
meeting the right people no it wasn't it
was a paranormal thing and one one thing
i do i did like about the movies have
haven't had
experiences that people would call
paranormal you know near-death
experience out of body experience
poultry guy stuff
this is like
a realistic portrayal of i didn't i've
never experienced anything quite like
this
i have had some
dreaming true out of body experiences
happening in dreams or kind of lucid
dreaming sometimes just out of body
experience that one time out-of-body
experience while i was just trying to
fall asleep other people saw it happen
and then uh near-death experience during
my coma
and this is just kind of like that's
kind of this is a good portrayal of what
it's like
it's not like something out of a damn
cartoon or
superhero movie or anything it's
naturalistic and it's kind of how they
show it in this movie i liked it really
i liked it well everything seemed very
plausible based on my personal
experience real plausible that things
like this happen
i kind of liked the way they um
you know they integrated
the past and the you know the past and
the present so it's like you weren't you
weren't entirely sure like i said it at
first it starts off what ends up
happening is she first goes to you know
the college and she stays in the dorm
and she ends up having to room with this
passive-aggressive [ __ ] named
jocasta joe costa was that that girl
yeah she was she's horrible big names
and [ __ ] and uh yeah just she's going by
her first name you know what i mean so
uh so that girl was just the worst and
so after all of this like bad [ __ ]
happens ellie decides that she's gonna
go like get a room so she goes to get
like a bed sit
and uh at that point she gets this room
that's running by diana rigg now this
was actually diana rigg's last movie
because she died in 2020. i didn't
recognize her uh yeah she plays the
landlord miss collins
and so she ends up uh you know renting
the room which belonged to sandy back in
the 60s
um so that's maybe why the connection
came about and at first she just starts
having like dreams about her but they're
really like realistic dreams where
she's kind of like her identity and that
of sandy are kind of like meshing into
one another like they keep switching
back and forth like when they they show
part of this in the trailer like where
they're at this big like nightclub scene
uh you know with sandy there and then
sometimes you see sandy on this side of
the mirror and then you see ellie on the
other side of the mirror yeah but then
sometimes you see ellie in place of
sandy and that's filmed really well like
i really like the way they integrated
that the way i interpreted that though
is that she's being shown sandy's past
and she's being shown it through sandy's
eyes yeah it's it's she's having not
an out-of-body experience where she's
being shown the past in that way
sometimes she sees it in first person
sometimes she sees it yeah that's a
third person uh which
that's a very dreamlike type situation
which that checks out for out-of-body
experience it's kind of like that
um
and there are some kind of like physical
manifestations too because she comes
back at one point and there's like a
hickey on her neck yeah and then there's
sometimes when she's seeing the past or
re-experiencing it on a couple of
occasions if you really pay attention
some of the people
that she's seeing seem to react to
things that she does
but she tries to get their attention but
you're not really sure
if you're just if she imagined it and
that's how you saw it it doesn't matter
it's it's ambiguous
but my take on it was is that
she was
going into the past and influencing just
a small amount of what was happening
um but she couldn't change anything
yeah because it had already already
happened yeah and like i said they
established early on that she has like a
psychic ability yeah so she's seeing
what happened or at least she's seeing
her perception like is being filtered
through her being perception
right so it's like she might be
misreading certain things like that
could be as well
but um yeah so i also really liked when
she first starts
having these dreams or visions or
whatever and they kind of show this in
the trailer as well is that she's really
into it like she can't wait to get back
to the apartment and like go to sleep
and everything like that because she's
kind of this little mousy shy kind of
girl but it's like just her
kind of associating with sandy like
she's getting changes her hair and like
starts being more confident
she starts living vicariously in a way
through sandy through these experiences
where she's kind of like
in possession of her in a way
uh of sandy
she's actually just being shown sandy in
the past i think she's going to the into
the past and seeing it yeah and actually
maybe people in the past may have been
aware that something paranormal was
happening or something strange that
happened they wouldn't have been aware
that a girl in the future had come back
to see it right but she would seem to
have been expecting the environment a
little bit
and because she was so
kind of sheltered and shy
she's now in the position of kind of
living vicariously through this wild 60s
really cool
club girl who can sing and entertain and
had dreams of being this star this
nightclub singer star
but it goes bad for her you know what i
mean but she did have this [ __ ]
connection to this chick because she was
really [ __ ] cool so
she tries to
solve this girl's murder you know what i
mean and [ __ ] it just goes from there
it's it's a lot of unexpected [ __ ]
happens uh [ __ ] well worth it okay i
enjoyed this one just as much as i
enjoyed dune they are very different
movies but i recommend this one too this
is a good one
yeah i like this one a lot i mean i knew
that i was going to like this one but i
think i liked it more than i was
expecting to i thought it was going to
be good but i was like yeah it's going
to be okay that was good really good
yeah and like i said i think like the
twists at the end i really liked where
that went because i didn't see it coming
right um always great to see terrance
stamp in a movie he's fantastic i love
him he's good in everything um man i
need to watch the limey again now that
i'm thinking about it but it's got good
horror [ __ ] in it action
uh in certain places got real good score
soundtrack um pretty compelling story
you get pulled into it pretty pretty
good good characters
um the characters in the past are really
cool uh real cool song and dance numbers
hot [ __ ] chicks
60s chicks [ __ ] doing cool [ __ ]
sometimes bad [ __ ] uh cool 60 dude who's
kind of like the [ __ ]
king of the scene and [ __ ] how he's
doing his [ __ ] you know
a lot of the [ __ ] he's doing you know we
wouldn't fly today because the 60s was a
very different time
but you could see how in the 60s that
dude would have been really [ __ ] cool
um was he cool uh you'll find out but
he was uh
all the dudes all the british dudes in
the 60s [ __ ] you see the difference
in the club scene back then you know a
lot of them were old a lot of these guys
were in their 50s and 60s still [ __ ]
throwing money around throwing their
dick around on these [ __ ] young girls
because these girls [ __ ] didn't have
jobs that's a bunch of old leches oh
electric [ __ ]
you know back in those days you know a a
single young woman couldn't really make
a living for herself she had she had to
have a boyfriend so
these dudes are kind of [ __ ] taking
advantage of that [ __ ] and um
but you know they just had some cool 60s
dances that they thought were cool in
the 60s and
like i liked that marionette one yeah it
was really good that was cool that was
like something from a cabaret from an
old 30s yeah yeah they're in a little
bit of a burlesque cause yeah for that
[ __ ] [ __ ] a lot of
[ __ ]
sexy [ __ ] lingerie at certain point
times you know [ __ ]
voluptuous [ __ ] hotties and [ __ ] you
if you guys will like it just as much as
girls will like it it's good danny
rowling asks if there's any nudity was
there i don't think there was um
if there was it was very brief there's a
lot of kind of like sexy outfits and
sexual innuendo and sexual innuendo i
don't know if there was any actual
most of it might have been implied
there might have been some boob but i
can't really simulated sexual acts but
it's real brief [ __ ] happening
girls blowing dudes behind stages yeah
that's what i was thinking it was a lot
of [ __ ] like that gone but it's nothing
a kid can't handle i don't think i don't
know well actually it's rated r isn't it
it is yeah so you know well because as
it gets darker it gets pretty
violent yeah let's get started
and bloody
and uh supernatural [ __ ] ghosts and
[ __ ] and [ __ ] all kinds of cool [ __ ]
happens in it yeah there's a lot of
there's a lot of ghosts like kind of i
liked the the look of the ghost like
this yeah
not only can she kind of go into the
past and res relive it
she's also being confronted in here and
now by ghosts that's all part of it too
ghost giving her messages and they're
real kind of vague she
she can't really see him too well you
just have to see the movie it's good
it's real good yeah i liked it a lot and
like i can't control her abilities she's
not some kind of jedi master with like
the ability to control [ __ ]
she's just got in the in star wars
terminology she would just have what
they call force affinity in other words
it
the force does things to her she can't
control it yeah she doesn't really have
any control over what she sees or when
she sees yeah it's doing it to her from
an outside
her subconscious just does it to her
ghost coming through her subconscious
and
they manifest too evidently
danny rowling says what's tomorrow's
show about doppelgangers
we're going to talk about doppelgangers
that's what won the poll i was going to
say two i really like yeah the um
the soundtrack for this
is incredible i would actually buy the
soundtrack for this not gonna lie um
mostly kind of 60s pop songs you got
like dusty springfield patula clark
sandy shaw um all that kind of stuff had
some 80 stuff in there had some sushi in
the banshees yeah uh happy house was
playing at the halloween party a lot of
cool 60s stuff
uh was in it too it's just [ __ ] that
gets caught you're cut uh
caught in your head like going downtown
downtown yeah so it's just in there you
know
yeah it's good i didn't realize the one
scene where um
where sandy
auditions and she sings downtown yeah
that's actually anya taylor joy that
actress that is actually her singing
okay yeah so i was just kind of like
well [ __ ] i thought it was i thought it
was probably like dubbed everybody no no
no if you go to drama school they you
you gotta learn how to sing you gotta
start they start with musicals yeah but
it's uh i kind of feel like it's pretty
common
for maybe not so much but i kind of feel
like back in the old days they'd always
have kind of like the actress and they'd
have some other like a professional
singer who got them over but that's
actually that's actually her singing a
decent actress can sing
yeah
they can sing but yeah so yeah she's so
she's saying downtown when she was like
auditioning and i liked too i noticed
something that a lot of the 60s
songs that were in this um
were covered in the 80s yeah i mean you
had always something there to remind me
they had the original for that which
was eloise
the damned did that one if you're gen x
you like [ __ ] punk rock and goth and
[ __ ] and new wave you'll recognize all
this [ __ ] and uh at the halloween party
other than the susan the banshee song
they also played ardene taylor there's a
ghost in my house which the fall covered
um but there was one other one too that
i can't remember what it was oh there
was uh got my mind set on you which
george harrison covered in the 80s um so
it's interesting so eva so even if
you're like an 80s kid and you and you
wouldn't know like the 60s original was
i knew like the original ones too but um
but if you didn't then you would
recognize them from the covers all right
so it's not really i think i've pretty
well established or hope to establish
with you people that you people um that
this is not really a disposable horror
movie most of them are disposable i can
tell the difference this one will
actually be remembered
uh i i believe so this will be kind of
like
the seven sins or
um
what else would you put it on par with i
don't know they'll remember this one i
think
uh well like i said i don't even know
this is a like a genre defying
movie yeah it definitely has horror
elements it's a bunch of genres because
like i said it has some creepy ghost
[ __ ] and it's violent and kind of bloody
like especially toward the end
um and there is good you know there's a
murder mystery element to it too but
it's there's a lot of other stuff going
on in this so it's kind of like yeah you
can call it a horror movie but that's
kind of like i guess that's a little
reductive i think i think it's a notable
movie i don't think it'll go down as
strong as say like the shining
i mean that's [ __ ] a classic of all
ties but it'll go down like some of the
ones that you remember from the 90s and
the 80s [ __ ] that you can name
i don't know if it'll do that box office
wise but just artistically when you see
it you'll remember it it does seem like
most of the uh horror channels that i
watch that i subscribe to uh have really
really dug this movie yeah it's good so
um good quality yeah
and it really does seem like really the
only criticism of it i've seen is that
some people didn't like they thought
like um you know the writing wasn't as
good but they talked about like how good
the visuals were and like the sound
design and everything but
honestly i mean i don't know like i said
i feel like most horror fans like really
really dug it i'll take this one over
the new halloween and i like the
halloween
but this oh yeah this is this is this is
way better well because i liked
halloween kills too but that's just like
a standard just a standard horror movie
this one is kind of like i would i don't
know if i'd go so far as to call it an
art film because it's not really an art
film but
it has
it's got it's got a lot more mainstream
appeal than a heart than than yeah
because i feel like even if you didn't
like horror movies you could still get
into this you know what i mean man what
would be a comparable movie as a classic
that's what i mean i'm trying to like
feel like because i you know i i listen
to like edgar wright like talking about
what his inspiration for this was and
like i said you know italian horror like
jealous movies because like i said it
does have a murder mystery element to it
it does have a very 60s look to it
there's
i don't want to say there's a little bit
of like funny [ __ ] in it but it's not
like you know like shawn of the dead
funny like it's not a parody or anything
like that it's pretty serious
but then it kind of has like an over the
top and i don't know it almost kind of
reminds me of like maybe
maybe like brian de palma or
something like those kind of like
like erotic thriller type things oh you
know what i was gonna say i was almost
gonna say it reminded me of eyes wide
shut but faster pace with better music
and [ __ ] better looking and a little
bit more yeah and like a little bit more
like over the top violence
yeah with supernatural stuff yeah that's
probably like it's really hard to like
think of something like i said he said
that repulsion was a big um
was a big uh
influence on this which i can kind of
see but repulsion
you know
this is like repulsion but like a jolly
movie but also like an erotic thriller
but then also like
a like a bloody
horror movie with ghosts in it
you know what i mean so like i said it's
like genre defying it's hard to kind of
like put my finger on i almost want to
say this is the story not the feel or
the motif but the story is almost
something kind of like out of one of the
star wars jedi role playing games where
you have like a young apprentice
jedi
trying to calm [ __ ]
restless spirits and solve a [ __ ]
murder to kind of restore justice and to
[ __ ] restore the balance of the force
and she but she can't use the force
she's like a novice it has that
concept
but it's happening in two different time
zones the 60s and the modern day it's
i liked it i liked it yeah i liked it a
lot actually i wouldn't mind seeing it
again to be able to see it again yeah i
heard the music
yeah i mean honestly yeah cool that
soundtrack is just yeah it was so so
good and it's just weird how you have a
you have like a psychic thriller that
has kind of like psychic investigations
and detective work
mixed with horror
and then there's song and dance acts and
[ __ ]
yeah from the sixties and it's like
all happening i like you're in these
clubs and [ __ ] yeah people are
[ __ ]
cool dance scenes and [ __ ] and you're
like oh no wow that's kind of kind of
interesting it's very stylish
yeah well i like movies that you can't
really put comfortably into one genre
i'm not saying that i don't like ones
that are just straight up horror movies
because obviously i do but
i like movies that are kind of like that
you can't really
super define she's standing there in the
audience you know in this in the past
and she's standing in the theater
watching auditions and watching shows
and she's just like blown away over how
competent these 60s girls are you know
they're all [ __ ] gorgeous they all
sing and dance badass costumes and [ __ ]
and then she's just kind of like
in some ways kind of like horrified with
what's going on you have all these
[ __ ] talented good-looking people
they're kind of getting [ __ ] over you
know yeah then she but she was
definitely impressed with the 60s but
she was impressed with the 60s before
she was fantasizing about it looking at
record albums and stuff
and making 60s clothes and [ __ ]
yeah because that's the thing i mean the
opening scene is her swishing into her
bedroom like in cornwall with a dress
that she made out of like old newspapers
yeah in a 60s cut in like a 60s cut yeah
and she's got like 60s like pop divas
like all over her walls and she has like
that old record player like that you
carried around like a little suitcase
over the fact today you know you we live
in an internet-based [ __ ] online
culture it's not the way it was in the
60s and even in the 80s [ __ ] was done in
person
if you were the [ __ ]
you had to be the [ __ ] in person not
online
you know and that's what she was seeing
she was like man these people [ __ ]
were on their game and and some of the
dudes were on their game but they
weren't all good
yeah that's you know
that's yeah that's the thing that's yeah
and part of the i think part of the her
journey in the movie is like her loss of
illusions yeah because she didn't live
through the 60s obviously
um so she was seeing it through very
idealized eyes like i said carnaby
street and all that really cool like
swinging 60s type of situation and uh
but there was like a dark side to it too
and like her coming to terms with that
is kind of like part of her character
arc yeah and then like uh they show
london in the 60s and they've got it
[ __ ] i don't know if it was a set or
if that was cg because all these neon
[ __ ] lights and signs and she's
tripping out she's tripping out through
the eyes
of sandy because she's living through
sandy and [ __ ]
during that one i was happy to uh to
discover that they did actually shoot
this in soho so it's not a set what um
i'm sure that they i don't know if they
cgi like to make it look old cgi'd it or
set dressed certain streets or whatever
but yeah it was pretty damn convincing
that it was cg all that neon on all
those bit all those buildings
going all the way up to the ceiling and
everything and just yeah i think that
must have been cg and i think it was
they were in that location yeah i think
they see g over cg over everything yeah
they probably did but all the stuff in
the modern day that was all shot in soho
which is unusual because you don't
usually i mean particularly like in big
city shoots you know famously in movies
shot in the united states if it's
supposed to be new york city it's almost
always toronto
because it's you know really hard to get
permits for new york city it's because
it's so busy and it's kind of expensive
and everything but this actually was uh
shot in soho so it was nice to see like
because i've been to like carnaby street
and all that area so it was kind of neat
to to see it all hasn't changed much
since i've been there but that was
probably like 2009 i think was the last
time i was there but um yeah it kind of
looks the same i just thought that was
like pretty cool and like i said i like
i like that they got like a lot of 60s
era
actors like diana rigg um you know rita
tushingham touching him whatever uh she
played the grandma
tarrant stamp obviously uh you know so
they had
so that was kind of like an homage so i
thought that was kind of nice too but uh
yeah this is like a really really good
flick like i said i wouldn't mind seeing
this one again uh next one we gotta see
is antlers
so nobody tell me
i'm not you know i'm not
like don't don't spoil anything don't
tell me if you thought it was good or
bad or whatever it's like because i just
want to kind of see it oh like we saw a
preview this is the first time i'm
hearing of this amazingly i'm like was
not up on my game i guess but we saw a
preview before this movie for the new uh
guillermo del toro movie which i think
is called nightmare alley and that looks
pretty cool too that looked like it's
set in like the 1920s
sort of it looked like sort of a
carnival sort of thing and i was like
ooh that looks right up my alley they're
in there they're in there arguing about
tom hardy's [ __ ] height that he was
too big to be mad at max and [ __ ] tom
hardy's [ __ ] short for what i
remember
he is jack though
yeah i thought he was i didn't know if
he was necessarily short but i thought
he was just like average height yeah
he's maybe uh five eight five seven see
that's what i thought like five seven or
something what that's not short yeah
inch or two taller than me yeah that's
not sure but uh yeah uh derek dr derek
from
more plates more dates covered
[ __ ] tom hardy's uh [ __ ] uh
steroid cycles so we we that we all know
what he took
no shame we're gonna we just gotta out
[ __ ] that [ __ ] does not happen
naturally you cannot gain 30 pounds in
four months
okay
well unless it's 30 pounds of fat you
know you can do that he got [ __ ] big
by eating mcdonald's every day yeah real
big for that one for that one movie
where he played that that [ __ ]
fighter boxer and then after that he did
bane and he was pretty big he still is
pretty big
um not to take anything away from him he
trains hard i've seen videos of him
training for those movies physically
um and what's funny is that he'll get
big and then he'll [ __ ] himself up for
another roll
those actors got it hard like you built
all that [ __ ] and they're gonna lose it
all just for this role
i'd pass up on that role and take
another role that you could keep that
body
so i don't know how their endocrine
systems go put up with that [ __ ] well
look at [ __ ] uh what's his name like
oh jesus christ christian bale he's
[ __ ] done like yeah those dudes are
nuts i mean that is gonna catch up look
look at what he did for like the
machinist where he basically starved
himself down to nothing and he looked
like
either i saw that movie and i'm like
that can't be real yeah it was he's like
i basically start he ate nothing but
like gum and cigarettes and then well he
didn't eat cigarettes obviously but then
when he was in remember he was he played
[ __ ] dick cheney yeah and he got he
back
out yeah like he gained all that weight
and i'm just like dude you are gonna die
like i just your heart cannot [ __ ]
take it well not only that just your
[ __ ] andricon system your ability to
[ __ ] produce testosterone and i know
they're all on exogenous [ __ ] they
inject all those hormones into them but
still your body does not like any that
up and down and up and down it's hard
enough on on on even just a [ __ ] pro
wrestler of having a normal
weight lifters physique and metabolism
and then take roids for a little while
and then come off of them just that is
enough to cause a [ __ ] to get
fat if you do it wrong all right all
this [ __ ] about roidin out for long
periods of time and then starving
yourself down to nothing that's way down
in the negative zone you know what i
mean and then coming and then coming
back and being fat and all that
i don't know about his body can take it
i really don't shouldn't be able to do
it not for long that well they're making
millions of dollars a movie so i guess
they're just like [ __ ] it i want that
six million dollars
i guess and and the thing about it is
worth my health man no i mean they have
the money and they obviously have
trainers and you know doctors and [ __ ]
like on retainer like to tell them hey
this guy you can do it the best way
right so it's like yeah but still it's
like a body it's just a body i don't
care how much money you got eventually
it's you gonna wear that [ __ ] out yeah
you can only do that so many times
but tom hardy though he's
studying what he's done i have a lot of
respect for tom hardy i like his work uh
i like his work ethic um i like what he
did with himself um and uh i think i i
think he'd make a great bond and i think
he's about the right age he could
probably pick up james bob now yeah he's
british
and james bond has to be british and he
has to be a male okay
and james bond is a white guy if you
want a black spy go get felix
and have a cia story
remember femur felix yeah yeah the last
felix was a black dude and i [ __ ]
loved that character what's that what's
that that actor's name he was also in
the in the first um he played one of the
guys in the very first um samuel l
jackson um
uh
uh shaft movies he played a guy in there
i forgot that guy's name but he uh so
there's all kinds of stuff just leave
them characters alone man [ __ ]
james bond's a white dude and he's
british
john goris says i heard his prison movie
bronson was good oh fantastic never he
said he never saw it yeah it's really
good fantastic it kind of it it's a
little bit surrealist yeah it's like but
i like that it it kind of reminded us of
uh clockwork orange a little bit it's a
clockwork orange but funny
yeah yeah like i said and it has like a
lot of kind of surreal aspects to it
it's it's super strange but i really dug
it loved it yeah sophie said it to us
right yeah sophie sent us the blu-ray
but yeah he's really really good in that
so yeah you probably see it's weird but
it's good i like when he trained for
that movie
he physically trained for it but he
trained as if he was could only use four
walls no weights
and he was on and he was eating shitty
food which that's what you would eat in
prison so it was nothing but just
standing on his head and doing that he
was trying to be as realistic
and it's because that inmate bronson
also was writing books about how to work
out in prison he evidently wrote books
on it
when mine wouldn't mind actually to see
that because that's how he
gained size in prison was just uh
standing on his head and doing weird
[ __ ]
like push-ups like against using his own
body weight to work out with
and see they'd put him in and then he he
would talk about what happens if they
put you in isolation and you're in that
little bitty tiny cell that you could
only stand up and how do you work out in
that and he's worked out ways to how to
work out in that thing where's that some
useful ass information just saying yeah
well that he sounds crazy but if you're
maybe if you're a professional soldier
or [ __ ] some kind of contractor
that'd be good to know because like i
said it's useful information if you get
captured and you're in [ __ ]
confinement and captured by the enemy
you're going to need something to keep
your mind [ __ ] sane
uh from long periods of incarceration
and possibly torture
so
if you can have some way to keep
yourself
challenged you know
outside of what they're doing to you
that could that could
help you keep your mind together
yeah you know so that would be very good
good i like to know weird [ __ ] like that
just in case
you never even know what could happen
well yeah i mean you know i mean you
can't be prepared for every contingency
but you know it's good to know how other
people have survived [ __ ] yeah that's
true yeah
uh rickshaw says fury road part two
please right i really wish they would
make another one yeah i wouldn't mind
actually to see a spin-off with furiosa
that's what i thought they were going to
do yeah i would watch the furious the
movie come on she was rad yep there
should have been a couple few the thing
is those things are difficult and
expensive to make they are yeah um
although the director what's his name
george miller george miller yeah george
miller said he
has a team of guys he trusts each one of
them to continue after he's after he
goes
yeah he's covered he's prepared for that
yeah he's prepared if he does he's got a
team of dudes he says can handle it that
they know exactly what it what what a
what a max movie is about because man
fury road was so yeah it's got to be
live action those have to be real cars
and you really have to wreck [ __ ] yeah
well yeah that was what was so that was
good man i loved that movie i think we
saw we saw that six times in the theater
yeah
and that was before we had a-list but we
paid for it watching it we just paid for
it six [ __ ] times it was just so good
and it was so good to see like on the
big screen like we have at home too
we've watched it at home like on the big
screen tv but it was way better in the
theater john says cape fear was the last
time denier was ever able to do any of
that craziness because yeah that was
actually his that was actually a really
good movie man we should do that for we
should do uh um a matinee on that
because i haven't seen that a long time
remember really digging that movie
i think it might be on amazon prime now
that i'm thinking about it
i can't remember well no maybe that's
the original i can't remember but yeah
i've seen the original too but i've seen
the the robert de niro one like more
recently
um all right so
is that all we have to say that's all i
gotta say about it yeah so yeah
seriously um
i really really liked last night at soho
like i said i i was expecting to like it
because i said man that looks super cool
but i liked it way better than i was
expecting to and
like if you've seen it tell me if you
saw the twist coming because i totally
did not
you know what i mean
and usually i can see stuff coming but i
didn't see that coming
there were a couple twists actually yeah
i mean and the first twist
i kind of saw that coming but i only saw
it coming like two like a couple of
minutes before
it was kind of revealed yeah so that
wasn't that big a deal but that last
twist i did not see that coming out
[ __ ] to see right now would be dune and
this one
yeah if you want to see a movie see if
you've seen dune go and see this one
it's worth it yeah and like i said if
antlers is good i'm going to go see
antlers sometime before the end of this
week and we'll see if that one's good
too because i've been looking forward to
that one
and uh then we'll see what happens so
like i said that nightmare alley one is
coming out i think that's the beginning
of december i'll have to go see that one
too that looks pretty cool but yeah so
uh i guess that'll do it for today's
show
and we'll be back tomorrow for the main
episode because tomorrow's wednesday
already
uh 5 p.m like i said it's gonna be about
doppelgangers which should be kind of a
fun show gonna be about
i i was telling him last night i was
like i'm gonna do cause i think there's
like an app where you can find your
whatever they call it nowadays your twin
stranger or whatever where you know it
uses facial recognition software to like
find
your doppelganger like somewhere on the
earth so i said well i'm gonna have to
remember to have to like to do that
before the show to see if i can find if
i have a doppelganger somewhere because
that'd be pretty freaky
but yeah so we will see you guys
tomorrow evening at 5 p.m eastern
standard time and thanks for dropping
bye